This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。嘿，大家近来如何？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）带来的《艰难求生》（Learn the Hard Way）。这个节目专注于黑人男性的真实经历，进行那些在别处实在不安全、无法坦诚展开的对话；但在这里，你是在和一位知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲？它向世界释放出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。收听《艰难求生》，
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
在IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
在IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听“2%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友们。在IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女友们，相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。
On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
在《回看当年》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说都是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。我们的嘉宾包括我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。
84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones.
84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试结果两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试结果。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格，一名男同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Jemisbe, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. So today we've got another one of our little bonus episodes. These are like shorter, more bite-sized doses of our usual content, something to like accompany your lunch break or your little morning walk. in these shorter chats, we just mainly aim to tackle certain terms, theories, concepts that you may hear in the self-help or psychology space in a more focused, compact kind of way. And in today's episode, we are going to be looking at this concept of detachment, specifically how we can truly detach from an outcome, from a person who is controlling our emotions, from a relationship, from a relationship.
在IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。大家好。我是杰米斯贝（Jemisbe），欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十岁时面临的最大变化、重要时刻和转折点，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客，新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听我们的又一期节目，当然，我们一如既往地剖析二十岁的心理学。所以今天我们迎来了另一个小加更节目。这些就像是我们常规内容的更短、更易消化的微型版本，非常适合在你吃午饭或进行晨间散步时陪伴你。在这些较短的聊天中，我们主要旨在以一种更聚焦、更紧凑的方式，来探讨你可能会在自助或心理学领域听到的某些术语、理论和概念。而在今天的节目中，我们将探讨“超脱”（detachment）这个概念，具体来说，我们如何才能真正做到超脱：超脱于一个结果，超脱于一个控制我们情绪的人，超脱于一段关系，超脱于
relationship, a situation, a job application, really anything. Our attachment to these things is deeply emotional. It shows we care a lot, but sometimes our emotional investment can actually cause us to suffer more in imagination than in reality and get too caught up in the what-ifs than the what is actually happening. Detachment is the psychological and emotional kind of antidote to this that asks us to perhaps be more stoic, to understand that what we think about something won't always change what will actually happen. And just to let life be something that happens to us naturally, that flows around us, rather than us trying to push through it or force certain things to happen or struggle against people who aren't going to change their mind, who may not treat us any
一段关系、一种情境、一份工作申请，甚至是任何事情。我们对这些事物的依恋带有极深的情感色彩。这表明我们在乎很多事情，但有时我们的情感投入实际上会让我们在想象中遭受比现实中更多的痛苦，并且让我们过度纠结于“如果……会怎样”而不是“当下到底发生了什么”。超脱是针对这种心态的一种心理和情感上的解药，它要求我们或许应该更具斯多葛主义精神，去理解我们对某事物的想法并不总能改变实际会发生的事情。我们要让生活顺其自然地在我们身上发生，让它围绕着我们流淌，而不是试图去强行推进、强行让某些事情发生，或者去同那些不会改变想法的人、那些可能不会对我们有任何
differently or situations that maybe aren't going to improve just by us trying to think about them more. It is an incredibly important skill. That being said, it's also quite difficult to learn. So let's talk about it. Firstly, what's the difference between attachment and attachment? It might sound simple, but attachment is, I always think about it as like having a bird in the palm of your hand and holding onto it really tightly with a closed fist hoping that it will stay. And that not being a comfortable experience for anybody or anything. Detachment is the ability to hold what you want or what you have with an open hand. Sure, the bird may fly away, but that probably means it wasn't meant to be there in the first place,
改变的人、或者那些仅仅因为我们花更多时间去思考就不会改善的情况进行抗争。这是一个极其重要的技能。话虽如此，它也很难掌握。所以我们来聊聊它。首先，依恋和超脱之间有什么区别？这听起来可能很简单，但我总是把依恋想象成手里握着一只鸟，用紧握的拳头死死抓着它，希望它留下来。这对任何人或任何事物来说都不是一种舒适的体验。超脱则是用开放在手掌中的手去把握你想要的东西或你拥有的东西。当然，这只鸟可能会飞走，但这可能意味着它一开始就不属于那里，
didn't want to be in there in the first place. And a new bird, a better bird, a bird that does want to be there is going to fly and land on your hand. that's kind of the metaphor I always think about. It's basically when you stop trying to bend reality into your preferred shape and you just decide to participate in whatever is actually happening without gripping, without bargaining, without trying to force things into place when they don't fit, detached from a specific outcome, detached from a specific person and their behaviors.
一开始就不想呆在那里。而一只新鸟、一只更好的鸟、一只确实想呆那里的鸟会飞过来落在你的手上。这差不多就是我脑海中一直想到的隐喻。这基本上就是当你停止试图把现实扭曲成你偏好的形状，并且决定参与到实际正在发生的事情中去时——没有紧抓不放，没有讨价还价，没有在事物不合适时强行将它们归位——超脱于特定的结果，超脱于特定的人及其行为。
You are very much in this mindset of what I can control and what I can't control and you notice the difference and you appreciate the difference. In the literature on detachment, psychologists sometimes basically describe it as a form of cognitive distancing or emotional distancing, being able to turn down the emotional volume of a situation or your own emotions just enough just to be able to think clearly and just to act in line with your values and your vision. It's not that you are going to numb yourself to any outcome. it's not that you're going to shut down.
你的心态很大程度上处于“我能控制什么”和“我不能控制什么”的状态，你注意到了两者的区别并且懂得知所进退。在关于超脱的文献中，心理学家有时基本上将其描述为一种认知距离或情感距离的形式，即能够稍微调低某种情境或你自身情绪的情感音量，刚好足以让你能够清晰地思考，并根据你的价值观和愿景采取行动。这并不是说你会对任何结果变得麻木。这并不是说你要关闭自己的情感。
It's not that you're going to stop caring. It's still about caring. It's just about being able to operate without the outcome or that other person or whatever it is, the event, being your center and being the thing that you obsessively think about. It's basically saying, don't let the things you can't control be the only thing that you focus on. when we're attached, what we're actually attached to is not always the outcome or the person or the situation or whatever it is. It's often what that thing represents and what promises us meaning. You're attached to this idea of getting this job because maybe that will prove to you
这并不是说你不再在乎了。这依然关乎在乎。它只是关于能够在没有结果、另一个人或任何事物、事件作为你的中心、成为你痴迷思考的事物的情况下运作。这基本上是在说，不要让你无法控制的事情成为你关注的唯一焦点。当我们产生依恋时，我们真正依恋的其实并不总是结果、人、情境或诸如此类的东西。它往往是那个事物所代表的东西以及它向我们承诺的意义。你依恋得到这份工作的想法，因为也许那能向你证明
that you are hardworking, that you are good enough, that you are set up for the future. You are attached to receiving attention from this person, not because you may be able to even like them, but because you think that their attention would give you some very serious sign that you are lovable. Or, you know, if they don't give you attention, well, then that's going to prove that you aren't. We get attached because as humans, our brains crave a feeling of safety and they crave a feeling of knowing. And when we have certainty over situations, that is the cheapest shortcut to feeling okay and to feeling safe in life. It's also not something that life has promised us. We are not going to be certain about many, many things. But our brain likes to convince us that
你很努力，你足够优秀，你的未来有着落了。你依恋得到这个人的关注，并不是因为你可能真的喜欢他们，而是因为你认为他们的关注会给你一个非常严肃的信号，证明你是一个值得被爱的人。或者，你知道，如果他们不给你关注，嗯，那就会证明你不是。我们之所以会产生依恋，是因为作为人类，我们的大脑渴望安全感，渴望一种“已知”的感觉。当我们对情况有确定性时，这是在生活中感到安心和安全的成本最低的捷径。这也是生活并没有向我们承诺过的事情。对于许多许多事情，我们都无法做到确定不移。但我们的大脑喜欢说服我们，
if we can think about it a little more, if we can manipulate the situation, a little bit more, if we can want it enough, well, then hopefully we can be in control. And hopefully that will give us a sense of meaning, a sense of predictability, a sense of certainty. And this is where our ego and the idea of self-concept comes into this as well. We don't just want that person. We don't just want that job. We want what it means and what it will say about us, that we are lovable, that we are chosen, that we are competent, that you have a bright future, that life will be happy. And if we don't get the certainty we want, if we are, if we don't get the outcome we want, then none of that is none of that feels correct. So the goal and the outcome that we get attached to deeply that is
如果我们能多思考一点，如果我们能多操纵一下局势，如果我们能足够渴望它，嗯，那么希望我们就能掌控一切。希望这能给我们一种意义感、一种可预测感、一种确定感。这就是我们的自我（ego）和自我概念（self-concept）的想法发挥作用的地方。我们不仅仅想要那个人。我们不仅仅想要那份工作。我们想要它所代表的意义以及它对我们的评价——我们是讨人喜欢的，我们是被选择的，我们是有能力的，你有一个光明的未来，生活会是快乐的。如果我们没有得到我们想要的确定性，如果我们没有得到我们想要的结果，那么这一切就都……这一切感觉都不对了。因此，我们深深依恋的目标和结果之所以对我们如此重要，
significant to us is so significant to us because it is fused with self-worth and self-belief. And so it takes on a much deeper level of control and weight than if it didn't mean those things to us. And just to note, attachment isn't inherently bad. It's actually quite a healthy organizing force that can really help us prioritize what and who matters and helps us allocate our attention and resources towards goals and coordinate our lives and gives us a sense of meaning. The issue really just comes when we are overly attached. And instead of helping us organize our lives and giving life a sense of purpose and importance and meaning and giving us goals, it actually has the opposite effect. Firstly, when we are overly attached to a specific thing,
是因为它与我们的自我价值和自信心融合在了一起。因此，它比不意味着这些事情时，承担了更深层次的控制感和重量。需要说明的是，依恋本身并非生来就是坏事。它其实是一种相当健康的组织力量，真的能帮我们分清什么和谁更重要，帮我们将注意力和资源分配给目标，协调我们的生活，并赋予我们意义感。真正的问题在于我们过度依恋的时候。此时它没有帮我们组织生活、赋予生活目标感、重要性和意义以及给予我们目标，反而产生了相反的效果。首先，当我们过度依恋某件具体的事物时，
our thoughts actually become a lot more narrow and they begin to race and it gives us a feeling that is very similar to anxiety or to rumination. It can get really obsessive, right? We all know that. Our thoughts might become more rigid and selective and you basically start forming a singular preferred interpretation of events and the only information that you let in is information that seems relevant or proves what you want to happen. Anything that doesn't do that, that doesn't point directly towards our target, gets ignored. Even if it is super important, even if it's something like a significant red flag in somebody's behavior, even if it is a thing about that apartment that is actually super inconvenient,
我们的想法实际上会变得更加狭隘，开始加速运转，并给我们一种非常类似于焦虑或反刍思维的感觉。它会变得非常强迫性，对不对？我们都知道这一点。我们的想法可能会变得更加死板和具有选择性，你基本上开始形成对事件的单一首选解读，而你放进大脑的唯一信息就是那些似乎相关或能证明你希望发生的事情的信息。任何不符合这一点、不直接指向我们目标的信息，都会被忽视。即使它超级重要，即使它像某人行为中一个明显的危险信号（red flag），即使它是那个公寓中实际上非常不便的某个方面，
something about that job that may actually not be great, because our thoughts are narrow, because they are more rigid and less curious because we are too attached to a specific outcome, sometimes we just ignore things that would otherwise definitely make us desire a different outcome. Secondly, our mood definitely becomes attached to a specific outcome. If we feel recognized by that guy, we feel amazing. But if they don't reply to us, we just feel terrible and worthless and low. If we get the job, we feel incredible. We feel purposeful.
或是关于那份工作实际上可能并不那么好的某点，但由于我们的想法很狭隘，由于我们因为对特定结果过度依恋而变得更加僵化、缺乏好奇心，有时我们就是会忽视那些在其他情况下绝对会让我们渴望不同结果的事情。其次，我们的情绪肯定会与某个特定的结果挂钩。如果我们觉得得到了那个男生的认可，我们会感觉棒极了。但如果他们不回复我们，我们就会觉得自己糟糕透顶、毫无价值且情绪低落。如果我们得到了这份工作，我们会感觉难以置信。我们觉得生活充满目标。
But if we don't hear back, we throw in the towel altogether. We swear that we're never going to bother trying to get a new job in that industry again. We question all these things about ourselves. And essentially, it's like the emotional systems in our brain become handcuffed to something that is outside of our control. And when that dips, when that plateaus, when that rises, our emotions are going to follow along with it. And we just feel completely unmoored in that way. Because we are no longer, you know, the driver. We are no longer in the driver's seat. We are completely in the passenger seat to whatever these, you know, circumstances choose to bring us.
但如果我们没有收到回音，我们就彻底放弃了。我们发誓再也不费心去那个行业找新工作了。我们质疑自己身上的所有这些事情。从本质上讲，这就像是我们大脑中的情感系统被戴上了手铐，拷在了我们控制之外的东西上。当那个东西下跌、当它停滞不前、当它上升时，我们的情绪就会随之起伏。我们在那种状态下会感到彻底迷失方向。因为我们不再是那个（你知道的）司机了。我们不再坐在驾驶座上了，而是完全坐在乘客座位上，任由这些（你知道的）环境选择带给我们什么。
The thing is as well, you know, the more we do care and the more attached we are, which again, is normal, the more we do try to push, force, fight, hold tight, the more we try to make a situation work that just isn't going to. And what that does is actually, I often think, reduces the chances of something working out. Sure, this relationship with this person might work out and might go well, but only if you give it breathing room. but in our desire for predictability and control, we try and speed up timelines.
问题还在于（你知道的），我们越在乎、依恋越深（这再次说明，这是正常的），我们就会越努力地去推动、强求、抗争、死死抓住，越会试图去修复一个根本行不通的局面。而这样做的结果实际上（我经常这样认为）降低了事情成功的几率。当然，这段与这个人的关系可能会成功，也可能会进展顺利，但前提是你得给它留出喘息的空间。然而，在我们对可预测性和控制欲的渴望中，我们试图加速时间线。
We try and, I don't know, we just, we become more obsessive and we do things that we know are actually counter to our overall goal. But because we are so attached, it just feels like this attachment has nowhere to go unless we take action on its behalf. And we end up ruining things. We end up putting too much pressure on things. we end up burning out, we end up feeling so exhausted that we withdraw or that we move on or that we feel like we can't be around somebody or in a situation, not necessarily even because
我们试图……我不知道，我们只是……我们变得更具强迫性，我们会去做那些我们知道实际上违背我们整体目标的事情。但因为我们依恋太深，以至于觉得如果不代表这种依恋采取行动，它就无处可去。最后我们把事情搞砸了。最后我们给事情施加了太大的压力。我们最终筋疲力尽，最后精疲力竭到选择退缩、选择继续前进，或者觉得自己无法和某人在一起、无法处于某种情境中——这甚至不一定是因为
of what they've done, but because of how we are approaching the situation. You know, I have this theory. It's not so much a psychological theory. It's definitely more of a philosophical, spiritual theory. But I always say if you are overly attached to something, to a relationship and outcome, whatever, such that you imagine in detail exactly how things are going to work out. You're already picturing the wedding. You're already picturing the new outfits, you're going to wear to your new job.
他们做了什么，而是因为我们对待这种情况的方式。你知道，我有一个理论。它与其说是一个心理学理论，不如说是一个哲学和精神层面的理论。但我总是说，如果你对某事、对一段关系或一个结果等等过度依恋，以至于你在脑海中详细想象事情将如何完美发展。你已经在想象婚礼了。你已经开始想象去新工作岗位时要穿的新衣服了。
I often think that's actually kind of has like a counteractive effect where it makes it less likely to happen. It's like in some universe, i.e. in your mind, this situation has already occurred. And so, you know, the universe isn't, or God or whatever, isn't going to repeat that same event. because it doesn't want to, you know, it wants to be creative. If you've already created the situation, it cannot possibly happen again in real time because, you know, yeah, the universe of the God, whatever it is, like it likes to be cheeky and likes to be, likes to keep us on our toes and likes to give us something different.
我经常认为，这实际上有一种反作用，即它使事情发生的可能性降低了。这就像在某个宇宙中（也就是说在你的脑海里），这种情况已经发生了。所以，你知道，宇宙（或者上帝，或者随便什么）不会重复同一个事件。因为它不想（你知道的），它想要保持创造力。如果你已经创造了这个情境，它就不可能在现实时间中再次发生，因为（你知道的，是的）宇宙或上帝（无论是什么）它喜欢调皮捣蛋，喜欢保持我们的戒备，喜欢给我们一些不同的东西。
So actually, the more you think about things and the more you try and imagine picture, develop this story in your head, the less likely it's going to occur. In fact, probably it's highly unlikely it's not going to occur the way you think it is. because of this principle and, you know, there's really no evidence for that other than my anecdotal evidence. But every time I found that I've clinged, or clung, sorry, I should say too tightly to something such that I've imagined all these hypotheticals, they have never come true. And it's always then ended up happening in a way that is completely surprising. And I don't know, maybe that's just the explanation that my brain has kind of gone to, to maybe teach me to stop overthinking it as much.
所以实际上，你对事情想得越多，你越是试图想象、构思、在脑海中编造这个故事，它发生的可能性就越小。事实上，它很有可能不会按照你想象的那样发生。因为这个原则（你知道的），除了我个人的经验之外，真的没有别的证据。但每当我发现自己紧紧抓着（或者说紧抓不放，抱歉，我应该说）某样东西太紧，以至于想象了所有这些假设情况时，它们从来没有实现过。而且它总是以一种完全出乎意料的方式发生。我不知道，也许这只是我大脑用来安抚自己的解释，为了教我不要再想得那么多。
I think as well, just on a broader sense, it just overly obsessing about a specific outcome, it basically reduces how open we are to other outcomes and to newness, how open we are to the unexpected, to the beautiful parts of life that really genuinely surprise us. And the acceptance and having space for those things is really what detachment is about. Instead of being rigid, wanting certainty, wanting an outcome that you think is best for yourself, we are more curious, we allow the events around us, the world around us to deliver the outcome that is probably better. We are more confident in ourselves. We trust ourselves regardless of what happens. And we're just simply more able, like better able to enjoy and witness things in our
我认为，从更广泛的意义上讲，对特定结果过度痴迷，基本上会降低我们对其他结果和新鲜事物的开放程度，降低我们对意料之外的事物、对生活中那些真正令我们惊喜的美好部分的接受度。而接纳并为这些事情留出空间，正是超脱的真谛所在。我们不再僵化、不再渴望确定性、不再执着于你认为对自己最好的结果，而是变得更加好奇，我们允许我们周围的事件、我们周围的世界带来那个可能更好的结果。我们对自己更有信心。无论发生什么，我们都信任自己。而且我们只是简单地更有能力——更好地去享受和见证我们
lives and experiences because we're not obsessing over them or getting attached before they occur such that we feel their loss much more profoundly. So we can talk about this till the cows come in, what do we actually do to get to a level of healthy detachment so that we can observe, be invested, but not, you know, emotionally tied to this situation so that we can really just have some more freedom in our lives, some more peace. We're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science.
生活中的事物和经历，因为我们没有在它们发生之前就对其念念不忘或产生依恋，从而导致当它们失去时我们会感到更深切的痛苦。所以我们可以一直聊个没完，但为了达到健康的超脱水平，我们到底该做些什么呢？这样我们既能保持观察、保持投入，又不会在情感上被这种情况捆绑，从而在生活中获得更多的自由和更多的平静。在短暂的广告休息之后，我们将探讨所有这些以及更多内容。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析
of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side
在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会引发炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-Sent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either.
成为一个更快乐、更充实、更 healthier（健康）的人。收听《2%》。那是T-W-O-P-E-R-C-E-N-T，在I-Hart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，永远不要惹乡村女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也永远不要惹她的朋友。
say that trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of The Girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
（总是说）相信你的女性朋友们。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《女友们》的这一新季中，天哪，这是同一个男人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个惯犯约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼，才不。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. You remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。在IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《女友们。相信我，宝贝》。还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA上拍打小吉姆（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English.
或者坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小吉姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回看当年》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克（Sam Jek）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过那段岁月的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他大谈80年代的快克（crack）毒品。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅是因为快克。我可以一整天都在聊快克，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里有一条主线了。
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people. black people in American history.
我们现在还谈到了艾滋病。谢谢你把那句话补充完整。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是黑人历史中最重要的一年。美国历史上的黑人。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't
在IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看当年》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难求生》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾进行的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于我们没有
realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person join me Keer Gaines is we have real conversations about healing growth father pressure and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
意识到我们已经拥有了这个东西，却还在继续追逐，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌，生活变成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得做一个好人很重要，还是说你当下的善良是因为恐惧？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的，那代表着两个不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正地去做一个好人。加入我的新播客《艰难求生》，我们将就疗愈、成长、父亲带来的压力以及人生目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle
打开免费的I Heart Radio App。搜索《艰难求生》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战
to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试结果两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试结果。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·莱斯皮安（Gregolespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，
as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So a lot of key principles around the art of detachment actually are heavily influenced by Eastern philosophy, particularly by Buddhist and Taoist principles of non-attachment. non-attachment is this attitude of flexibility and balance towards life experiences where we can interact with our thoughts, our feelings and events without clinging so desperately to desired positive outcomes or fearing negative ones. What this concept is based on is this idea that the
劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在IHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。所以，围绕超脱艺术的许多核心原则实际上深受东方哲学的巨大影响，特别是佛教和道教关于无执（non-attachment）的原则。无执是一种对生活经历保持灵活性和平衡态度的表现，在这种态度下，我们可以与我们的想法、感受和事件进行互动，而不会绝望地执着于渴望的积极结果或恐惧消极的结果。这个概念的基础是这样一个观点：
nature of our experiences and our mental representations are actually constructed. They're not permanent so they can't hurt us unless we let them because we can always just allow them to move on and we can always just let them go. I know that sounds very silly and like a very simple explanation, but people for thousands and thousands of years have been adopting this way of approaching life. The simplest way to maybe get into this mindset, the simplest reset is before you try to fix anything, just giving yourself a literal physical space to see things clearly. The fastest way is by, you know, physically distancing yourself, getting out of a room, getting out of a conversation, getting out into the world, so your attention isn't trapped into this tiny loop of whatever it is you're obsessing over. You need to be in a different environment or situation from the one that is causing you stress.
我们的体验和心理表征的本质其实是被构建出来的。它们不是永恒的，所以只要我们不放任它们，它们就无法伤害我们，因为我们随时可以允许它们继续前行，随时可以放下它们。我知道这听起来很傻，而且是个非常简单的解释，但成千上万年以来，人们一直在采用这种方式来对待生活。也许进入这种心态最简单的方法、最简单的重置就是，在试图解决任何事情之前，先给自己留出一点真正的物理空间来把事情看清楚。最快的方法就是（你知道的）通过身体上的拉开距离，离开房间，离开对话，走到广阔的世界中去，这样你的注意力就不会被困在你所痴迷的那个微小循环中。你需要置身于一个与导致你压力的地方或情境不同的环境或情况中。
When we feel overly attached to something, I really just think we can't see the woods from the trees. We become so overly focused on specific, tiny, minuscule details that we lose the perspective on the rest of our lives. We lose the ability to understand the larger overall situation. We lose the ability to, you know, realize that other people are alive at the same time as us and to just put our problems into perspective. This version of detachment is just the simplest form. Go outside, move your body, do some kind of intense exercise, let your senses reset, Put time and space between the stimulus and your response. Also, a part of this is just to start really paying attention to the ordinary world.
当我们对某事感到过度依恋时，我真的认为我们往往会“只见树木，不见森林”。我们变得过于专注于具体、微小、极其细微的细节，以至于失去了对生活中其他事情的全局观。我们失去了理解更宏大整体局势的能力。我们失去了（你知道的）意识到其他人也和我们同时活在这个世界上，从而把我们的问题放在正确视角下的能力。这种版本的超脱其实是最简单的一种形式。走到户外去，活动你的身体，做一些高强度的运动，让你的感官重置，在刺激和你的反应之间留出时间和空间。此外，其中的一部分还包括开始真正关注平凡的世界。
The sounds, temperature, people walking their dogs, look at other people just living their lives. And that will allow you to realize that this might feel incredibly serious and life-defying for you, but it doesn't take up the whole universe. And one day it won't be at your epicenter anymore as well. we often feel like if we focus on the issue or the goal just a little bit longer, if we work just a little bit harder, if we analyze their response just once more, you know, we will have control. We will be able to, you know, problem solve this situation,
声音、温度、遛狗的人，看看其他人是如何过着他们的生活的。这将使你意识到，这件事情对你来说可能感觉极其严重、关乎生死，但它并不会占据整个宇宙。而且总有一天，它也将不再是你的核心所在。我们常常觉得，如果我们再多关注这个问题或目标一会儿，如果我们再多努力一点，如果我们再多分析一次他们的回应（你知道的），我们就能掌控一切。我们将能够（你知道的）解决这种情况，
but this never happens. This is a classic thought spiral. There are limitless things and ways to see this situation, limitless things to think about, limitless possibilities. You thinking about them more is just adding fuel to the fire and just further convincing your brain in your mind that one more second to think about it, one more second of rumination, one more moment to attach even further is somehow going to get you an answer or is somehow going to give you certainty. By gaining literal distance,
但这永远不会发生。这是一个典型的思维螺旋。看待这种情况有无限的事物和方法，有无限的想法，无限的可能性。你对它们想得越多，就越是在火上浇油，更进一步地说服你大脑中的心智：再花一秒钟去想它，再多一秒钟的反刍，再多一个让依恋进一步加深的时刻，不知怎么的就能给你一个答案，或者不知怎么的就能给你确定性。通过获得切实的距离，
you are widening your frame of reference so that you are allowed to choose how to respond rather than just having to react, and you are able to really identify this problem or this situation for what it actually is rather than what your mind is making it out to be. So the next move is to refill yourself so that your worth isn't hanging on one reply, one meeting, one person, one thing going right. As we saw earlier, one of the key aspects of being overly attached to something or someone is that our sense of self-worth often begins to be contingent on that thing happening.
你正在拓宽你的参照框架，这样你就可以选择如何去回应，而不只是不得不做出反应，并且你能够真正认清这个麻烦或这种情况的本来面目，而不是你脑海中所夸大的那样。所以下一步是自我充实，这样你的价值就不会悬于某一次回复、某一次会议、某个人、某件顺利的事情之上。正如我们前面看到的，过度依恋某人或某事的关键方面之一，往往是我们的自我价值感开始取决于那件事是否发生。
So it's really crucial that we start to re-center this back onto ourselves, re-anchor ourselves back into us. Just really practice the opposite of humility and the opposite of being attached or devoted to something or someone else. Stroke your own ego. Celebrate how freaking amazing you are. reinforce that you'll be fine without this thing. For the next day or two, flood your schedule with proof that you exist well beyond this
所以，至关重要的是，我们要开始把这种中心重新转移回我们自己身上，重新将自己锚定在我们的内在。真正去践行与谦逊相反的事情，以及与依恋或对他人或事物的奉献相反的事情。抚慰你的自我（ego）。庆祝你是多么的惊艳。强化这样一种信念：没有这件东西，你也会过得很好。在接下来的这一两天里，用各种证据填满你的日程，证明除了
goal or this person or whatever it is you have in mind. Go out for dinner. Create something. Buy yourself like a really hot new outfit. Get a haircut. Do anything that makes you feel novel, makes you feel confident, makes you feel in your energy, in your power. Make as many plans as possible that don't include the person, the thing.
这个目标、这个人或你心里的任何东西之外，你依然活得很好。出去吃晚餐。创造点什么。给自己买一件（真的很好看的）新衣服。理个发。做任何能让你感到充满新鲜感、感到自信、感到沉浸在自己的能量和力量中的事情。尽可能多地制定不包含那个人、那件事、
the event, the situation, the place that you're attaching to. If you're dating, make sure you're also dating your friends, exploring your city, having evening plans, building out the world beyond this thing that has taken your focus, making sure that there are all these other things that you're excited by and investigating and curious and, you know, just motivated to see so that your whole world isn't just whatever it is you're obsessing over. Detaching, you know, it isn't about not caring. It's about ensuring that your world and your life is big enough that no singular thing could come in and suffocate everything else out. You can be engaged in the parts of your life or in the people in your life that you do feel attached to.
那个活动、那种情境、那个你所依恋的地方的计划。如果你在约会，确保你也在和你的朋友约会、探索你的城市、安排晚上的计划、拓展这个夺走你注意力的事物之外的世界，确保有所有这些其他的事情能让你感到兴奋、去探索、去保持好奇心，（你知道的）仅仅是有动力去见证，这样你的整个世界就不仅仅全是你所痴迷的东西了。超脱（你知道的）并不是关于不在乎。它是关于确保你的世界和你的生活足够宏大，以至于没有任何单一的事物能够侵入并窒息其他一切。你可以参与到你生活中那些你确实感到依恋的部分，或者你生活中的那些人。
You just can't be fused. You just can't have an emotional over-reliance on something going right or somebody liking you or a situation working in your favor to determine whether you're going to be happy for that day. The next thing or the next tool is to really ask yourself, does this fit? Or am I sanding the edges of myself or of my life to make it fit? Now, I think we have a little bit of a gut reaction when I mention this or when I talk about this. When something fits, you know that it fits. Like there is ease there. It's like the perfect pair of jeans.
你只是不能与之融为一体。你不能在情感上过度依赖某件事进展顺利、某个人喜欢你或某种情况对你有利，以此来决定你那天是否会快乐。下一个事情或下一个工具是真正地问问你自己：这真的合衬吗？还是说我在削足适履，为了让它合衬而修剪自己或生活的边缘？现在，我想当我提到这一点或谈论到这一点时，我们都会有一种本能的反应。当某样东西合衬时，你心里是知道它合衬的。那种感觉就像是毫不费力。就像那条最完美、最舒服的牛仔裤。
Like imagine your most perfect comfortable pair of jeans. It's no friction, no tension. They're always going to be amazing. When you try on a bad pair of jeans, it's pretty noticeable. And you can convince yourself that you'll change for the jeans, that the jeans will stretch, whatever, they never do. And you end up throwing them out, you end up donating them, you end up having to sell them anyways.
就像想象你那条最完美、最舒适的牛仔裤。没有摩擦，没有拉扯。它们总是会那么棒。当你试穿一条不合身的牛仔裤时，那是相当明显的。你可以说服自己你会为了牛仔裤而改变，牛仔裤会撑大的，不管怎样，它们永远不会变大。最后你还是会把它们扔掉，把它们捐出去，反正你最后还是得把它们卖掉。
Like, you know, and you know about certain relationships, you know about certain situations. as well. When something fits, plans get made. Replies don't need decoding. Your life doesn't necessarily feel like you're spinning plates just to stay afloat. You feel steady without constantly needing to be fixing things or tending to the situation, feeling burnt out, feeling awfully, terribly stressed. You know, when it isn't a fit, like you do feel that. There's lots of persuading, lots of justifying, lots of what if we just try this or this or this kind of energy and it's a very desperate feeling which we don't like we don't like feeling that to give you another metaphor like think of it as like
就像（你知道的），对于某些关系、对于某些情况，你也是心知肚明的。当一切合衬时，计划自然会制定。回复不需要解码。你的生活不一定让你觉得像是在转盘子，仅仅为了维持不沉没而苦苦挣扎。你感到坚定，不需要不断地去修复事情或照料这种情况，也不会感到筋疲力尽、感到可怕的巨大压力。你知道的，当它不合衬时——你是真的能感受到的。有大量的说服、大量的辩解、大量的“如果我们尝试这个或那个”这种能量，那是一种非常绝望的感觉，而我们并不喜欢。我们不喜欢那种感觉。为了给你另一个比喻——把它想象成
a jigsaw piece the wrong decision something that we're overly attached to that isn't right is like trying to force the wrong jigsaw puzzle piece into a picture that's already been made you have one piece left and you're so tired you're so exhausted you think that this last piece is going to be, this last couple of pieces is going to be right and it just, it's not working. You press harder, you cut off a corner, and you can just visually see it doesn't fit. And you will always know that it's wrong. And the whole picture becomes warped around it. It just doesn't look okay.
一块拼图。错误的决定、我们过度依恋却又不对的东西，就像是试图把一块错误的拼图硬塞进一幅已经拼好的画里。你只剩下一块拼图了，你累极了，你筋疲力尽了，你以为这最后一块拼图——这最后几块拼图会是对的，但它就是……就是行不通。你用力按压，你剪掉一个角，你能直观地看到它根本不合适。而且你总是会知道它是错的。整张画都围绕着它变了形。它看起来就是不对劲。
And I think relationships and goals act in the same way. If it only fits when you're shrinking, over explaining, carrying 80% of the load, you're forcing it. And there is another puzzle piece somewhere in that box. There is another puzzle piece that maybe somebody else needs to find and give to you that will fit better and you just have to wait. And I know that can be frustrating advice, but I can think of all these times where I just release the need to know and I released the need for a specific outcome and each time I was deeply rewarded. And it was much, much better than what I initially wanted. Two great examples of this are like my, the last place that I lived, like the first place I ever lived alone, this like my beautiful
我认为关系和目标的作用方式也是一样的。如果它只有在你不断缩小自己、过度解释、承担着80%的负荷时才合衬，那你就是在强求。而在那个盒子的某个地方，还有另一块拼图。还有另一块也许需要别人去找到并交给你、会更合衬的拼图，而你只需要等待。我知道这可能是令人沮丧的建议，但我能想起所有这些时刻：当我放弃了“必须知道”的需求，放弃了对特定结果的需求时，每一次我都得到了深深的回报。而且它比我最初想要的要好得多、好得多。这方面的两个绝佳例子就像是我的……我住过的最后一个地方，我一个人住过的第一个地方，这就像我美丽的
little dingy one-bedroom house, that house was perfect for me. And before that house, I'd actually applied for another apartment. And it was like the first or second one that I'd seen. And I just got myself convinced that this was the right one. And I was so anxious and stressed about it. And the thing was is that that apartment would have been terrible to live in. It was like on the bottom floor, there was no light. There was no public transport. there was no parking, like, but my mind had just convinced me, like, that's the one. And I was clinging onto it, clinging onto it. And when I didn't get it, it was actually quite relieving, and I'm glad I didn't, because then I got the thing that was better for me. It's the same with
那栋破旧的小一居室房子对我来说简直完美。而在那套房子之前，我其实申请过另一套公寓。那大概是我看的头几套房子之一，我当时就说服自己这就是对的那套。为此我感到非常焦虑和压力山大。但问题是，如果真的住在那个公寓里会非常糟糕。它在底层，没有光线，没有公共交通，也没有停车位，但我的大脑就是说服了我，觉得那就是对的。我紧紧抓着它不放。而当我没能租到它时，其实感到相当解脱，我也很高兴自己没租到，因为后来我得到了更适合我的东西。这就像
my last corporate job. I applied. I didn't hear anything for months. I detached. I basically told everyone like, oh, I'm not going to get it. I didn't get it. Like, I basically gave everybody else, like I told them what the outcome was without knowing. And, I genuinely think like a week later I got like a call about that job. And you know, these are just stories. Detaching doesn't necessarily increase the chance of an outcome happening. But I think it just lets you suffer less, enjoy life more and have a more positive open outlook to other things that are coming your way. My last tip is to just really try and adopt this stoic mentality we've been discussing throughout this episode. Focus as much as you can list in your notes up, in your jokes,
我上一份公司的工作一样。我申请了，几个月都没听到任何消息。我抽离了。我基本上告诉所有人，哦，我肯定进不去了，我没被录取。就像我基本上提前把结果告诉了所有人，甚至在不知道结果的情况下。而且，我真心觉得大概一周后我就接到了关于那份工作的电话。你知道，这些都只是故事。抽离并不一定会增加某种结果发生的几率。但我认为它能让你减少痛苦，更多地享受生活，并对朝你走来的其他事情保持更积极、开放的态度。我的最后一个建议是，真正试着去采纳我们在整集节目中一直在讨论的这种斯多葛学派心态。尽可能专注于
as much as you can, what you can control and what you cannot. That is detachment in the most grounded sense, recognizing that life is not going to arrange itself around your preferences, and knowing ahead of time that you're going to be okay with that anyways. You can want something and you can still refuse to make your well-being hostage to it. Bad things might happen, plans might change, you might not get what you really desired, you trust yourself enough to know that you're going to be okay. And we talk about self-trust so much on this podcast, but it is the opposite of anxiety. It is the opposite of anxious attachment. It is the opposite of panic. It's the opposite of rumination. It's just, I trust myself. I know that, yes, these things could happen. Yes,
尽你所能去区分你能控制的和不能控制的。这才是最脚踏实地的抽离感，认识到生活不会围绕着你的偏好来安排，并且提前知道无论如何你都会没事的。你可以有所渴望，但依然可以拒绝让你的幸福被它绑架。坏事可能会发生，计划可能会改变，你可能无法得到真正想要的东西，但你足够信任自己，知道自己会没事的。我们在播客中经常谈论自我信任，但它是焦虑的反义词。它是焦虑型依恋的反义词。它是恐慌的反义词。它是反刍思维的反义词。它只是，我相信自己。我知道，是的，这些事情可能会发生。是的，
things could not work out. I'll still be all right. I will still be able to be tested and come through this. And I think that that really is like the most positive way to think about anything that is out of your control is like, yeah, try me. Like I'm ready. My self-trust in myself is deep. I'm unshakable based on whatever is going on around me. And just think about how different your day feels when you have that mentality. The thing is, you're still going to show up, you're still going to ask what you want, you're still going to prepare, you're still going to have an open heart, nothing about the effort you put in changes, but the meaning you assign to the result softens. Yes, becomes an opportunity and no is just information that you use for next time.
事情可能会不如意。我依然会好好的。我依然能够经受住考验并挺过来。我认为这真的是看待任何超出你控制的事情最积极的方式，就像是，来吧，尽管试试。我已经准备好了。我对自己的信任根深蒂固。无论周围发生什么，我都不可动摇。想想看，当你拥有这种心态时，你的一天会有多么不同。事实是，你依然会出席，依然会争取你想要的，依然会做准备，依然会敞开心扉，你投入的努力没有任何改变，但你赋予结果的意义变得柔和了。是的，变成了一个机会，而“不”只是你留着下次使用的信息。
Neither is a measure of your worth, which is so important. It's just a refusal to confuse your preferences and a certain outcome with, you know, happiness and with necessity. Like, you're going to be okay, no matter what. I know this episode has been more of a pep talk than maybe like specific tips, but I really do feel like this is an energy, this is a real mindset that you float into and once you're in, you really understand how much more peace comes with it. And it takes time. I'm definitely not the best at it.
这两者都不是衡量你价值的标准，这一点非常重要。这只是一种拒绝把你的偏好和某个结果与幸福以及必需品混淆的态度。不管怎样，你都会没事的。我知道这一集比起具体的建议，更像是一场打气鼓劲，但我真的觉得这是一种能量，是一种你融入其中的真正心态，一旦你进入这种状态，你就会真正明白它会带来多少内心的平静。这需要时间。我绝对不是做得最好的那一个。
But when I do actively try and force myself to just consider other outcomes, to just really relax into whatever's going to happen, will happen, whatever will be will be. I genuinely feel the tension shift out of my body, and I find my approach to things changes, and people notice that, and they respond back to me in a way that is honestly, surprisingly, more positive. So I hope that this is convincing. I hope this episode was helpful. I hope you can apply it in your own life, whether it is with a situation ship, a job,
但当我积极地试着强迫自己去考虑其他结果，真正放松下来去接受“发生什么就是什么，顺其自然”时，我真的能感觉到身体里的紧张感消散了。我发现自己处理事情的方式也变了，人们注意到了这一点，并且以一种老实说、出乎意料地更加积极的方式回应我。所以我希望这能说服你们。我希望这一集对大家有所帮助。我希望你能将它应用到自己的生活中，无论是暧昧关系、工作、
an apartment, a friend, just the life in general. Yeah, I hope it goes far for you. I want to thank our research assistant Libby Colbert for her help on this special bonus episode. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Our December guest month starts in a couple of days and we have some amazing guests for you guys. So I'd love for you to be, I'd love for you to know when their episodes air. Make sure you're also subscribed, following whatever it is, whatever app you're listening on to the podcast as well so that you also get those notifications. and leave a comment in the description if you have made it this far.
公寓、朋友，还是仅仅是日常生活。是的，我希望它能对你大有裨益。我要感谢我们的研究助理莉比·科尔伯特（Libby Colbert）对这期特别福利节目的帮助。请确保在Instagram上关注我们：That Psychology Podcast。我们的12月嘉宾月将在几天后开始，我们为你准备了一些非常棒的嘉宾。所以我希望你能关注我们，希望你知道他们的节目何时播出。请确保你也订阅或关注了你正在收听播客的任何应用程序，以便你能收到这些通知。如果你已经听到了这里，请在评论区留言。
What are you trying to detach from right now? What is this episode hopefully helping you move on from, tread more lightly with. I'd love to hear it. But until next time, stay safe. Be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Care Games.
你现在正试图从什么事情中抽离出来？希望这期节目能帮助你放下什么，让生活变得更轻松一些。我很想听听你们的看法。但在此之前，请注意安全。对人友善，对自己温柔。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听《艰难学到的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师和主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Care Games）。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations, that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit are armored? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在其他地方真的不太安全，但你是在跟一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲？这向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去这样做，
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness,
在iHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学到的教训》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神韧性、
fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the Iheart radio app,
体能以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字是TWA%，在iHeart电台应用程序、
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends.
Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。在iHeart电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我来说也很重大。我是山姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利希（Alex English）。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
在每一集中，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论80年代。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》节目。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the iPhone. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iPhone、Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证是真人制作。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。